let's talk a little bit about the latest
news just in advance of tonight's debate
in the Democratic primary field because
Cory Booker has ended his presidential
campaign he's the latest since I guess
since marianne williamson to drop out
Cory Booker's campaign never really got
going polling 1.8 percent as of
yesterday he did get all the way up to
nearly 6 percent back in February that's
almost a year ago basically just
downhill from there with the occasional
spike to 3% the Democratic senator from
New Jersey put out a statement where he
said quote it was a difficult decision
to make but I got in this race to win
and I've always said I wouldn't continue
if there was no longer a path to victory
our campaign has reached the point where
we need more money to scale up and
continue building a campaign that can
win money we don't have and money that
is harder to raise because I won't be on
the next debate stage and because the
urgent business of impeachment will
rightly be keeping me in Washington so
as as Cory Booker points out he did not
qualify for tonight's debate and he's
decided it's time to call it quits and
he's right I mean that there's the
analysis here does not need to go too
far beyond that looking at the polls
more generally the next people who
should drop are Tom Styer a 2.2 percent
Tulsi Gabbard at 2.3 percent Amy
Klobuchar at two point eight percent
certainly at this point in time if you
were below three you should be out
remember you need 15 percent in
primaries to get any delegates and then
you know Andrew yang at 3.5% maybe he
can justify staying in a little longer
to see if he gets any delegates out of
Iowa Michael Bloomberg at five point
eight percent can justify it
if the DNC changes the rules for
qualifying for debates and he gets into
debates he can certainly justify it I
saw some people posting on Facebook that
Cory Booker didn't win because of racism
without denying that we are still
dealing with racism in this country Cory
Booker was not particularly progressive
he was not particularly good at debating
he was not particularly inspiring in
terms of policies so to say
that were it not for Booker being black
he'd be the nominee seems very flimsy
Booker's ideas weren't that great he
wasn't that great at expressing them in
a way that inspired support so his
campaign weight went nowhere I actually
think it's a good thing that Democrats
who can't win the nomination are
starting to exit we want diversity of
opinion we want different people with
different ideas but when you look at
back at that 2016 Republican primary
there were some people who stuck out the
2016 Republican primary way too long
from day one we basically suspected that
this would be a Biden Bernie Warren race
and it is Pete Budaj edge is trying to
stay in but he's not really making any
progress in the last six weeks this is
what it seemed like it would be at the
start and it's what it is now is that a
self-fulfilling prophecy to some degree
what I mean by that is did the fact that
so many people believed it would come
down to Biden Bernie Warren make it so
at the exclusion of other candidates
it's a possibility
but again there's a reason many people
believe that in a lot of the comments
about Cory Booker dropping out I saw
comments like you know Andrew yang is
the only person who can actually beat
Trump or Tulsi Gabbard is the only
person who can actually beat Trump I
hope that those folks eventually come
around to whoever is the eventual
nominee and help us defeat Donald Trump
we saw in 2016 what losing by small
margins in a few states leads to it
leads to four years or maybe even eight
years of Donald Trump four years or
maybe even eight years of the United
States as the laughingstock of the world
and a malignantly malignantly
narcissistic president who can't be
trusted to tell the truth about anything
while installing radical judges all over
the place who will rain hell on the
judiciary for decades to come so no
matter what you think now when I see a
comment like only yang or Tulsi can win
or even only Biden or Bernie can win I
hope everybody will come around and help
defeat Donald Trump when we get to
November because otherwise we're in big
trouble we'll have continuing coverage
of this on the David Pakman show
Instagram page at david pakman show
follow the instagram page follow me on
instagram at david pakman as well